in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding Chef I'm going to give you the
confidence that recipes and The Insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
sliced around
wasting nothing
I made my name cooking some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
in my restaurants I expect Perfection
every play has to be worthy of a
Michelin star and every time you make it
taste it as well yeah every day changes
now I'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes for fantastic
food that you can cook easily at home
incredible I'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better
do everything from how to cook on a
budget to bacon real fast food and my
ultimate feast recipes this is the only
cooking course you'll ever need
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
this is my guide to cooking with spice
adding big gutsy flavors using spices at
the beginning of cooking and then simply
letting the dish slow cook is a
brilliant way of getting maximum flavor
with minimum effort
my first recipe melts in the mouth and
because the oven does most of the work
it's a cinch to make slow cooked fiery
lamb cooking's all about being bold and
adventurous and this dish is exciting
because it's slowly cooked and the
longer it Cooks the more flavor
something it becomes the
marinating the lamb first chillers we're
going to use a mixture of red and green
take off the tops
and just slice
in
garlic
crushed
don't worry about chopping these ultra
fine just
get it in there cooking for up to three
hours
everything sort of Blends and almost
sort of
pures itself together
smoked paprika goes brilliantly well
with the chilies two teaspoons in a
touch of dried oregano
some little cumin seeds the blend and
the fragrance that they give out is
extraordinary they release a little oil
as well and helps to tenderize the lamb
touch of salt
pepper
cinnamon
that sort of sweetens up the lamb
olive oil
just a tablespoon and the olive oil
helps to sort of stick all those
wonderful spices to the lamb Chomp in
just start really rubbing at this stage
you can leave the lamb to marinate for
anything from half an hour to overnight
allowing with spices to really penetrate
the meat giving amazing results when you
tuck in delicious vegetables carrots and
onions and that's it sliced
cigarette slicing vegetables for
braising is not getting too thin you
slice the onions too thin they burn
you've got that horrible Char taste on
that slow braised braising it's just a
chef's term that means cooking in liquid
on a low heat making the meat incredibly
moist and beautifully tender so the
secret of braising is having a really
nice thick
durable pan
get that nice and hot
Touch of olive oil
lemon hold the bone because you're in
control then into the pan
you want that white fat to start
rendering so it'll add more fat
therefore making it a lot more
flavoursome as it braises
chillers cinnamon
in mix that up
and don't be scared you're not burning
this you're sort of searing the lamb
shanks and this is the important part
right at the very beginning we're going
to color on the lamb which washes off as
it braises in the oven so be generous
with that color
vegetables in
wow and then a couple of Baileys
so now you lift the lamb up
and get the lamb
sat on top of the vegetables
now delays the pan with red wine
the glazing means that you're you're
cleaning the bottom of the pan and
you're getting that amazing flavor
washed off and lifted up into that sauce
it can really transform that dish always
delays then bring it to the boil and
cook for about 10 minutes to reduce the
wines reduce down by half now for the
stock
bring that stock back up to the ball and
then into the oven now don't cover it
when you cover it all the condensation
comes off the lid your lamb becomes gray
all this effort and that exciting spice
gets washed away no lid and in the oven
for three hours
I slow cook on a low heat of 160 degrees
gives the spices time to work and
transform the meat so it's
mouth-wateringly tender now
look at those
out on to a plate you can just see that
meat sliding down
juicy and creamy tender grab it by the
the shank rolling around that rich
delicious sauce
look at that
and get your sauce
isn't that beautiful just get some mint
don't chop it just pick that fresh mint
and let it
snow and there you go a very spicy
delicious melting in the mouth lamb
shank amazing
foreign
to get the most out of your spices
there's only one piece of kit that you
need pestle and water I mean they look
fantastic and it's essential for any
good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pestos
to dressings and cost them around 15
quid
used to grind spices and you'll max out
on Flavor get perfect textures and
always be totally in control make sure
you've got a nice large circumference of
the bowl
so you can grind away the heavier the
more durable they are the more
confidence it gives you when you're
pounding and there's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand pounded
grab yourself a pestle and mortar and
soon you'll be spicing with ease
spices are a brilliant way to add an
extra layer and a depth of complexity to
any dish learning to use them properly
will really improve your cooking here
are three more of my super simple spice
recipes to get you going
[Music]
first up a very easy chili and spiced
white bait
start with the spice coating
toast Szechuan peppercorns and coriander
seeds in a hot dry pan to release their
flavors
add chili flakes and grind the pestle
and water to make a fiery fine powder
combined with plain flour season and mix
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
coat white bait in the spicy flour mix
then fry
white bait are an oily fish they are
healthy delicious and cooking minutes
once golden they're done
fantastic with garlic mayonnaise or a
simple squeeze of lemon
[Music]
ready in under 10 minutes chili and
spice white bait and easy simple spicy
dish
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on razal hanud a
classic Moroccan spice blend in a dry
pan toast Cinnamon cloves coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped Ginger
fizzle with olive oil season and
sprinkle over the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allowed to cool and place in a blender
tahini a Nutty paste made from sesame
seeds cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon
juice and a drizzle of olive oil
flits into a luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my final deliciously spicy dishes
curry spice sweet corn soup
[Music]
first The Fragrant curry paste
roast coriander and cumin seeds until
aromatic
then grind add in crushed garlic chili
powder turmeric and finely chopped
Ginger
[Music]
bring together with olive oil to form a
thick paste
for the soup fry finely chopped onions
in olive oil
[Music]
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors
add cubed potatoes
chicken stock
and season
when the potato has softened stir in
creamed corn
then add whole sweet corn kernels with
some of the juices
and transfer to a blender and Blitz
until smooth
for texture add more whole sweet corn
[Music]
it's ready to serve
[Music]
wonderfully satisfying curried spiced
sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly
aromatic punch
three more stunning recipes that make
cooking with spice simple
incredible
[Music]
this is my guide to cooking with spice
next up my shopping guide to buying
spices
[Music]
when I buy my spice I only want the best
and it always pays to get expert advice
Burger has been selling every spice
Under the Sun in London's not a hill for
over 20 years so she really knows what
she's talking about I love spices to
smell the texture
color spices are so versatile something
very very simple can be really
transformed into something really
delicious with thousands of aromatic
ingredients on a shelf if it smells good
she sells it if you're buying spices buy
them whole then you can try roast them
grind them when you need them and then
they will release the essential oils
whole spices you can keep for years give
them a good bushing wine bottle with
your rolling pin or whatever and you see
there is still Aroma and you can taste
it you smell it then it's fine
there's four main spouses one is sweet
one is sour one is bitter and one is hot
this is cinnamon and that is really a
great example of a sweet spice when you
buy cinnamon quill like this you have to
check that you have loads of different
layers in here then you can either grind
this or you'd break a piece off I mean
this doesn't smell of anything now
but if you roll it in your hand just
quickly like this
and then you smell it again this is just
unbelievable if you have spaghetti
bolognese put a pinch of cinnamon in it
to bring out the flavor
this is one of those
really special spices sour like a lemon
but it has a salty aftertaste I use this
anywhere for marinades to salad you
haven't lived unless you tried it a
great example for a bitter spice would
actually be a turmeric this is actually
a root it grows in the ground like
ginger use it very very sparingly about
that much well actually color you a
curry or a rice dish wonderful yellow
watch your fingers you get really yellow
fingers from it and then we come to the
hot spices one spice that I couldn't
miss and that is Hungarian paprika
paprika is the powdery form of a bell
pepper what makes the Hungarian paprika
different is that they actually grow it
on Vineyards it's sort of between the
vines it has a sweetness and it has a
sharpness to it I have it in ice cream I
have it on fish I have it everywhere
Burgers spot on about the power of
spices to transform dishes where there's
Savory or sweet here's my quick guide to
the spices I use most
spice I couldn't do without always buy a
hole and grind yourself so you get the
freshest flavor cardamom these pods come
in green or black types and have a
fantastic Spicy Sweet Taste brilliant
for everything from curries to rice
dishes and puddings
coriander these citrusy seeds are
perfect whole in pickles or grind to use
in fragrant stews and soups
cumin a Savory Spice that's pungent and
nutty it's great in marinade for
delicious Meat and Fish
then cinnamon sweetly fragrant and great
with apples or in cakes
and Nutmeg warm and spicy it's delicious
and a vegetable sauce finely saffron
these sweet strands Infuse a brilliant
bright red color and are great in
risottos and even though it's more
expensive than gold a pinch goes a long
long way store your spices properly and
they'll last for years you keep it
airtight in a tin or in a glass jar in
your cupboard
don't be scared of spices like an
aftershave or a perfume you have to
select it yourself it has to fit in with
your taste and with your kitchen
supermarkets and good local shops sell
an amazing array of different spices so
there's no excuse for not being
adventurous be bold find what you like
and spice up your cooking
like all chefs I love the challenge of
transforming classic recipes giving them
a new twist to make them modern and
vibrant
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored British
classic but with addition of spices it
gives a new lease of Life fragrant spice
rice pudding I love cooking with spices
but you don't have to just cook Savory
dishes using aromatics and spices across
desserts takes your puddings to a
completely different level
[Music]
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod fragrant and packed full of
flavor use the back of the knife and
flatten it that removes all those little
seeds off the skin of the vanilla pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up the smell
is incredible take the tip of the knife
and you scrape inside and look
at all those seeds dying to come out
that is incredible there are thousands
of seeds still ingrained to the Pod so
put them in to the casserole cardamom
powerful spicy
take two little pods place your knife on
top
lightly crack them cracking the cardamom
pods helps release all the amazing
flavor cloves because of that kind of
aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick
snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding is
in the taste of turn on the heat lightly
toast those spices just a couple of
seconds and what's going to happen is
just going to sort of enhance those
spices in a way that it just draws out
an even more powerful fragrance coconut
milk in
sugar
two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream
bring it slowly to the boil to allow the
flavors to infuse and this rice pudding
reminds me of my time in India where I
got really into that chai tea fragrance
because it was just so delicious and so
comforting
take a lime
in the lime just cuts through the
richness of the coconut gives it that
nice little bit of acidity goes
fantastically well with the cinnamon and
that fresh vanilla
nice have a taste
now let's come up to the boil give it a
nice little clean around the outside
and then with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs all that coconut
vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out for
three to five minutes
bullying it rapidly the rice opens up
and it goes into mush I want to keep
that nice texture of that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury
I'm going to show you how I take this
simple delicious aromatic rice pudding
to a completely different level here's
what I do take
two egg yolks separate them
and give that a really nice whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
we started into the egg yolks
so it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard turn off
the gas add that
into the rice pudding what happens it
starts to enrich and really thicken this
rice pudding and takes it to a
completely different level
the rice is still not cooked started to
go nice and soft you can just see how
it's opening up
but looks like Rich aromatic lava
bubbling away
finally Great Mall Citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
a rice pudding
is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees to finish cooking the
rice and develop the intensely aromatic
flavors
look at that
an incredibly fragrant rice pudding how
beautiful does that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
I'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
next my tricks of the trays and kitchen
tips
first how to zester Lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith watch the following technique
and I'll show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this which is the
fine zester not the big rough one not
the one for slicing and not the other
one for grating this little one here
onto a plate because it's always easier
to lift off on the plate than it is the
board and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes but
twisting the lemon round every time we
go down we twist
same with the orange and same with the
lime
tap
if you go too far
let me just show you look we've got that
white bitter pith that destroys the
wonderful
zesty flavor and look that's what we're
looking for there this really nice
vibrant lemon zest delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finely chopping
and mincing is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root Ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavor left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
foreign
My ultimate cookery course crammed with
key lessons
tips
and 100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better Chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the app store for details
go on get cooking
pack with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on right
now it's all about cooking with chili
[Music]
for me chillies are an incredible
ingredient in The Cook's Arsenal capable
of transforming dishes adding excitement
heat and a wonderful taste I'm going to
show you how to get the grips with their
intense flavor first up red mullet with
sweet chili sauce
it's about being adventurous and having
the confidence to go off peace and being
a little bit more daring so when you
start combining peanuts chili flakes and
this amazing fish red mullet trust me
you're in for an amazing treat
we're going to make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half
and those seeds inside are very powerful
incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin
so it helps the puree
chilies in the pest and water garlic in
salt and it will touch
sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions I want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in
the coriander slice it once
in
fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with the red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
hmm
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful
the longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's gonna coat the top of
the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander
mix the coriander in to the peanuts and
look I like them quite textured I don't
want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly to coat the fish with the chili
and peanut seasoning in a separate Bowl
beat two eggs along with a splash of
fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down
cover that red bullet
oh beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice and
piping hot if we put the fish in and the
Pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chili
it's just going to slide off the fish so
we need to sear it in and get it nice
and crisp in and lay away from you
beautiful
[Music]
pan starts getting a little bit too hot
get your eyeball
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
we want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed crispness which adds A really
lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with a really
nice piping hot olive oil you've got
that really nice roasted Crunch and it
goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside gas off
and just leave them sitting in there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one now and take them out
in the sauce
touch on the bottom and the tail of each
fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut encrusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies isn't all about blow your head
off heat this dish uses the exciting
Taste of a chili but has a deliciously
elegant and subtle flavor
as you become more confident using
chillies you'll find they can transform
your cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes Anchovies
and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice anchovies and
garlic
[Music]
dried chilies great for keeping the
cupboard to add a hit of heat on demand
[Music]
then add the anchovy oil to a hot pan
and Fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
chopped black olives and salted Capers
cook to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great store-covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain add to the sauce with a splash of
the water it's full of starch which
gives a great silky consistency
then season with pepper and top with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
and Cherry and chilies
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
foreign
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soak Chipotle chilies in hot water these
are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
together and season
[Music]
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
easy to eat grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter and utterly delicious Smoky
treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
foreign start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first Scotch bonnet chilies they may be
small but pack real heat and a fruity
punch
then chopped garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves
cinnamon nutmeg
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
to cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
three different chilies
three amazing flavors
three irresistible dishes
[Music]
next five more of my 100 tips that'll
make your life easier in the kitchen
first up how to deseed chili to get the
seeds out hold it upright and just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot you're just releasing
them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
Smarties
and there
got the little bottom bit off
amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilies
using string tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand chilies are
surprisingly versatile if you love them
in Savory dishes my tip is to try adding
them to melted chocolate ganache for
chocolate chili truffles or sprinkled
over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon a great tip to prevent
burning sensitive skin when working with
chilies to get rid of that spice and
that heat on your fingers a little bit
of lemon squeeze a little bit of lemon
juice and that instantly gets rid of the
heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a Mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of Kick
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on I'll be
showing you an amazing spicy beef salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
and just go over the beef but first the
secret to cooking fantastic food is to
start with great ingredients the more
you know personally about where your
ingredients are from and how they
produce the better so don't be scared
ask lots of questions and learn and when
it comes to chilies there's no one
better to ask than chili grower Joanna
Plum who's been farming chillies from
mild to mind blown for over 11 years I
eat chilies all the time every single
day she grows over 60 Types on her farm
and really knows her poblanos from a
habaneros
people think that chilies are all about
heat actually it's about Flavor as well
some are sweet some are aromatic and
they can be used in so many different
dishes when you go shopping and you're
looking for a chili what should you be
looking for what you want to do is look
at the chili and it needs to be nice and
firm and glossy generally the bigger the
chili the milder it's going to be the
smaller the chili the hotter and if it's
small and wrinkly like this one it's
going to blow your socks off another way
to tell if a chili is hot or not is to
split it open and smell it if it's a
super hot chili it'll clear your sinuses
the heat of a chili comes from an oil
called capsaicin and that is
concentrated mainly at the top of the
chili where the seeds are now when
you're cooking with a chili and you want
the flavor of the chili but not too much
of the heat start with just using the
bottom of it as you get closer to the
seeds that chili is going to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat there's
thousands of varieties out there because
they cross pollinate very very easily
and that's why the world's hottest chili
is always changing
Joanna's right with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
Aromas and of course levels of heat it's
important to buy what you like here are
my top chilies whatever your desired
kick
at the mild end poblano these are great
for stuffing have a delicate flavor and
often used in Mexican dishes
starting to get hot the jalapeno when
they're green they're like spicy bell
pepper the redder they are the sweeter
they are bird's eye where they really
start to pack a punch long thin and
pungent they're great in Thai Dishes and
are often green or red and at the top
end the habanero these Lantern shaped
demons have a delicious fruity taste and
they're the firecracker of the chili
World another way to use chilies is to
smoke them and to make chipotle what it
is it's just a Mesquite smoked red
jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can almost get
that like Smoky bacon sort of flavor out
of it so you would use this and anything
that you would slow cook so you're
eating a chili and it's really too hot
for you the best way to get rid of that
heat is to drink some milk or a dairy
product like yogurt whatever you do
don't go for water or for beer don't be
frightened of trying new types of
chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen
they give you a natural high much like
when you've been exercising so your
endorphins are released and you just
feel good chilies make you happy and
they're also an aphrodisiac
South East Asian Chefs they're brilliant
are balancing the hot spices of chili
with sweet sour and salty flavors
if you want a new Twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but have wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad
chillies if you use them confidently
they can really add a new dimension to
the style of cooking but the real trick
is finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly season the steaks generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the sirloin out of the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly but
more importantly you can actually season
right inside the steak this little bit
of fat down here season that as well
because that is what we want to roast
and get that really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon roll that
round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away again into the pan and lay
away if you don't hear that noise the
minute those steaks hit the pan don't
put them in so the secret now is getting
that color on the steak turning it once
and once only and cooking it for two and
a half minutes each side what I want to
do is to get that bit of fat rendered so
it adds a lot more flavor just hold
the steak down like that and that starts
to melt the fat which makes it so much
more tender there should be no white fat
left anywhere
turn them over really important to have
that stake up to room temperature before
you start cooking it so the inside is
nice and warm so he spend less time in
the pan and more time cooling down
really important
now two fingers touch
it goes in it says rare I'm happy for
them to be rare Because by the time I
let them rest
I'm going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them rest
one
two
get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chili Works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it to get your
knife and just
slam it down it pops out very very
quickly in it'll touch the salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it purring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chili and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce fresh lime this is a simple
fresh chili dressing and it was
something I fell in love with in Vietnam
and Cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar quick taste
wow right vegetables great fuss-free way
to get super thin ribbons of carrot is
to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension of the
salad and we use a banana shallot they
are incredibly mellow pretty sweet
across
just chop up
the shalom
and mix that through I want some
Sweetness in there now little Vine
Tomatoes slice them in half tomatoes in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes next
peel and sliced cucumber chopped spring
onions and Shred baby gem lettuce and
then finally get some fresh mint it's
young mint so you don't need to take all
those stalks off all you do is hold a
bunch upside down and then take it for a
little trim
and just chop that once through
through look at that nice minted salad a
couple of tablespoons of dressing don't
flood the salad with the dressing you
can always add but we can't take it away
now really mix that dressing in there
make sure all that chili and garlic and
palm sugar wraps around that salad
beautiful
onto the plate the steaks rested it's
now nice and medium rare a little bit of
fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
kept that steak nice and moist
slice going with the grain it's almost
like slicing through butter and look
inside
beautiful pink you slice the beef too
thinly then it goes Stone Cold and more
importantly all the goodness runs out of
it nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
sit that on top and finish it off with
some toasted peanuts peanuts in
now there's nuts are really toasted nuts
on
get another pan and just
a crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
you can hear how crunch they are another
texture under the taste of the salad
and then from there sprinkle
finally take that just finish it with a
little tablespoon of that sauce and
there is one tasty very well textured
spicy beef salad
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
foreign